Peggy's 16 when I was young I found an  orphan wolf cub in the forest behind our  farm I felt if I could instill rules the  proper boundaries I could harvest the  raw power of that beast a few months  later while hunting we're fixing the  damage the Avengers did all those years  ago Inhumans are sick  that's dangerous it's lethal  lucky to be alive come on Kamala let em  help you I'll take my chances  what if the Avengers were set up I think  you should see for yourself  mr. stark help us with this hi I'm sorry  who are you oh come on it's better be  good you tried to drive the Chimera have  you completely lost your senses where  were you while the world went to hell  this is our fault of ours you really  think the world is better without us yes  it's always been you cool  who you are what you are  [Music]  [Music]  I will  with me  [Music]  you  today's